il y a trente ans encore l'idée que des
petits hommes verts puissent peuple et
l'univers appartenait à la fiction
hollywoodienne mais ces dernières années
la recherche scientifique semble de plus
en plus indiqué que la vie
extraterrestre est plus que plausible si
certains scientifiques sont encore
prudents sur le sujet d'autres y croit
dur comme fer et aurait même des preuves
c'est le cas de l'astrophysicien avis
loeb directeur du département
d'astronomie de l'université de harvard
scientifique reconnu il est convaincu
que les extraterrestres existent si j'ai
raison c'est la plus grande découverte
de l'histoire de l'humanité
il ya quelques temps c'est un général
israélien à la retraite rahim échec qui
a affirmé quant à lui détenir des
preuves de l'existence des martiens
cette coopération se traduit par
l'existence d'une base secrète sur mars
ou des américains et des représentants
extraterrestre travaillent de concert
selon lui le président américain donald
trump était en contact avec cette
société et aurait même failli révélé au
monde entier ce secret alors croyez vous
à une vie que ça terrestre alors est ce
ça revient de plus en plus dominé de
fillols est avec nous vous êtes
passionné de science fiction et par
l'exploration des mystères du monde nous
avait rencontré les plus grands experts
sur la question des extraterrestres
avait réalisé le documentaire le bureau
des ovnis qui passera sur canal+ lundi
soir à 22h45 s'achever regarder
obligatoires alors je pouvoir garder un
premier extrait de ce documentaire il
s'agit de rencontres rapprochées chorus
un frère et une soeur avec un ovni et
ses occupants en août 67 à cussac comtal
plus acteurs ont fait rien le récit de
leurs témoignages avaient été recueillis
par la gendarmerie et le geipan est ce
que c'est que dépend le groupe d'étude
des phénomènes aérospatiaux non
identifiés
ça c'est sur canal + 1 2 heures 45
regardez l'extrait et j'aurai des
questions posées parce que c'est vrai
que de plus en plus il ya des phénomènes
paranormaux notamment ici autour de la
femme à cussac en 1967
une fillette et son grand frère âgés de
9 et 13 ans partent conduire des vaches
dans un pré il y avait une
bull qui étaient présents dans un champ
à côté de l'endroit où garder leurs
vaches elle faisait à peu près dans les
cinq six mètres de diamètre grosso modo
et avait des personnages qui évoluent
autour les deux enfants voient quatre
petits êtres qui semblent surpris par
leur présence ces petits êtres prennent
alors la fuite et regagne l'objet par le
haut en volant dans les airs
alors ça c'est extrêmement sérieux comme
études dominique c'est pas un charlot
loosli s connus mais nous dire déjà un
truc hyper important que vous me disais
en off c'est qu'il ya une organisation
depuis 40 ans qui s'occupe des
phénomènes paranormaux
voilà enfin des phénomènes aérospatiaux
non c'est à dire qu'en france c'est un
service qui est unique au monde
ça s'appelle le geipan main j'ai pensé
le groupe d'étude des phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés qui fait
partie du centre national d'études
spatiales
donc en fait leur travail c'est de
récolter et donc été sur les témoignages
liés aux ovins et ça ça existe depuis
ils ont travaillé sur des cas la plupart
des cas en fait ils les résolve c'est à
dire que ce sont des satellites des
rentrées président des météorites des
gens qui confondent avec des étoiles des
avions des planètes la plupart des cas
c'est ça mais il reste un pourcentage
qui défie toute explication je n'étais
pas le savez vous il reste il reste en
fait à un pourcentage qui qui on
n'explique pas qu'on n'explique pas et
là c'est là en fait où la mission du
japon s'arrête l'hymne au niveau où ils
vont dire bah ça on ne peut pas
l'expliquer et dans ces cas il ya des
choses absolument incroyable comme les
comme vous venez de voir juste avant du
sac ou deux enfants
60 oui moi je me raconte mais c'est
vraiment moi je vous crois moi mais vous
avez raison mais après moi je trouve ça
très au sérieux
c'est hyper intéressant malaisie pour
moi c'est pas un problème qu'on rigole
du sujet si ce qu'on l'a bien vite et on
n'a pas de souci non mais dominique au
contraire mais en fait je sais pas du
tout quand ça c'est parce que j'allais
sortir une valve catastrophique
vous avez parlé du geipan et je voulais
tellement plus que mon frère peter vous
connu des phénomènes paranormaux
dominique sais c'est quoi les trucs non
identifiée parce que à chaque fois on
parle du loup hubert lui qui disent des
bêtises
non mais c'est vrai les jours 10 voilà
c'est ce que c'est vrai ou pas ce qu'on
a prévu des vrais trucs par exemple en
france
en france bien sûr il ya eu des gars il
y en a il y en a il y en a beaucoup en
fait quand je vois ce que j'encourage a
fait un autre spectateur c'est d'aller
sur le site du geipan le site du geipan
il a tous les dossiers sur le phénomène
ovni depuis des années 50
il récolte les témoignages de
gendarmerie de l'armée de l'air on a des
pilotes qui ont vu des choses des halles
ça a commencé dans les années 50 on a on
a des mecs c'est quoi l'histoire de
maurice masse par exemple alors et
l'histoire de maurice masson valence est
incroyable cette histoire c'est le 1er
juillet 1965
on a un agriculteur donc là bien entendu
j'attendais la blague ne va d'accord il
est dans son champ et 5 heures du matin
c'est un mec sérieux est connu il s'est
passé pas quelqu'un qui boit c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est connu au
village quelqu'un d'honorable et dans
son champ tout d'un coup ils voient un
objet ils pensent que c'est une voiture
il se rapproche et là il voit deux
ptizêtres en train de ramasser dallas
vendre et qui rassemble derrière un
espèce de soucoupe volante en forme de
ballon de rugby et ils se rapprochent et
turquie où ils avancent about him to win
qui si ce qui motivera les télétubbies
parce qu'elles sont ils sont assez
petits dans nos c'est vrai mais ils ont
des gros seins est aussi il racontera
donc il arrive il ya donc deux petits
non mais c'est vrai les poulains de
l'histoire de petits êtres qui sont en
train de ramasser de la vendre ils se
rapprochent way est un des deux petits
sets en espèces de bâton en direction de
maurice menacé maurice m'a se retrouve
paralysée revenir et se retrouve
paralysé les deux petits êtres entre
dans le vaisseau le vaisseau part sauf
que là si vous voulez il ya des marques
au sol
il ya des marques au sol ça interpelle
les gendarmes qui viennent des
lendemains qui entendent parler de
l'histoire maurice masque lui se cache
plutôt de cette histoire donc il le
raconte juste à son pote du café du coin
lui va le répéter à tout le monde et
c'est comme ça que l'histoire est connue
lui il aurait préféré que ça ne se sache
pas mais il est des conditions partie il
était plus paralysé il est resté
paralysé à peu près un quart d'heure
après d'accord d'accord et il a vu donc
qu'il y avait des traces au sol les
gendarmes aussi on s'est vu qu' il y
avait des arbres sur le côté dans la
trajectoire de décollage de l'engin
ces arbres ou été brûlés ça ça a été
constaté et il n'y a plus rien de
pousser à l'endroit où ces projets
d'oser pendant plus de dix ans non voilà
et la terre est devenue dure comme du
béton
ça ce sont des choses qui ont été
constatés donc oui on peut se marrer
tout on peut sembler les autres sur wii
mais c'est un sujet je trouve qu est-ce
que celle dont on aurait été en france
c'est dangereux
cette escapade en or il n'y a pas de
preuve de
de d'hostilité de ces ovni en général
justement plutôt c'est de la crainte
il ya des histoires comme ça de
rencontres rapprochées bon là les quatre
valensole comme ça avec des petits êtres
ou tussac ça reste extrêmement rares
voitures mais comme ce sont des cas
comme ça de rencontres rapprochées en
général il ya plutôt ne de la méfiance
vis-à-vis de l'humain donc c'est comme
s'ils avaient plutôt peur de nous qui
nous voyaient comme une espèce
dangereuse et eux ne sont pas hostiles
qui croient qu'ils croient gilles verdez
on le sait oui oui alors pour compléter
ce que vous dites en france beaucoup de
gens ont encore peur de témoigner
max que ils sont ridiculisés moi j'ai
mon meilleur ami qui dans l'est de la
france avec la famille a eu une
rencontre qu'on appelait rencontre du
troisième type comme le film c'est à
dire qu'il a rencontré des
extraterrestres avec sa famille une
première fois ils ont signalé aux
autorités
et après ils ont été ridiculisés on les
a dissuadés aujourd'hui ne veut plus
témoigner
bien sûr que les extraterrestres sont là
et il faut que les gens parlent il faut
que les gens qui les rencontrent et le
courage de parler ils seront peut-être
ridiculiser mais c'est pas grave ils
vont vous c'est sûr qu'on n'est pas
seuls bas dans mon documentaire mon
dernier documentaire ovni une affaire
d'état j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
habile homme que lundi là vous parliez
tout à l'heure qui a parlé de au moins
moi comme étant juste vous voulez poser
la question sociale il évoque la
question solo à la rue on va voir sa
réponse à parfaire
il pourrait y avoir des civilisations
qui sont beaucoup plus avancés konya et
oui si on est à villé condate convoi des
preuves de ces civilisations
ce sera un show ce serait comme un homme
des cavernes qui regarde un téléphone
portable et essai de l'interpréter comme
un caillou une civilisation
technologiquement très avancé c'est
presque l'équivalent de dieu ont
apparemment on en serait on ne serait
pas seul je voudrais juste dire qu'il
faut regarder ce documentaire
lundi ce sera sur canal+ 22h45 je serai
kita c'est sûr et certain
est-ce que vous avez un autre cas
ajouter à nos téléspectateurs qui n'ont
pas qu'ils sont un peu sceptiques là
dessus je les encouragerai soit regarder
ce qui se passe en ce moment un peu du
côté des états unis depuis 2010 est il
est très beau être un bien entendu mais
il ya des des médias très sérieux comme
le new york times cnn qui parle depuis
2010 est en fait on a appris qu'ils
avaient un programme secret de recherche
sur les ovnis qu'élu entre 2005 et 2012
et est financé à hauteur de 22 millions
de dollars par le sénateur harry reid
que j'ai rencontré également et en 2017
ils ont dévoilé trois vidéos sont allés
par des chasseurs américains des f-18
donc on parle de pilotes de l'us navy
qui ont filmé des phénomènes qu'ils
n'expliquent pas et le pentagone